vamos ya con directo a hasta Washington
la capital de Estados Unidos con nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez Y es que
la jornada política en el país se ha
visto marcada por dos noticias de
impacto de un lado la multa que recibió
y la empresa del ex mandatario Donald
Trump por evasión fiscal del otro la
polémica por los documentos clasificados
encontrados en la residencia de Joe
biden Cristóbal una multa de 1,61
millones de dólares a las empresas de
Donald Trump que para muchos es
considerada como simbólica por qué
es considerada simbólica porque 1,6
millones de dólares es bastante poco
para una organización acostumbrada a
manejar billones de dólares en Estados
Unidos y lo que dicen ya muchos
analistas es que se va a tener que
revisar la legislación financiera en
Nueva York porque pues en muchas
empresas pues le sale de alguna manera
no tan costoso hacer este tipo de
crímenes Fiscales y crímenes financieros
sí la deuda va a ser de apenas uno coma
seis millones de dólares Esta es la
deuda más alta que se le puede cobrar en
el estado de Nueva York a las
organizaciones en este tipo de crímenes
financieros recordemos que las
organizaciones de Trump fueron ya
hallados culpables de 17 crímenes
financieros entre ellos
falsificar balances financieros y
también fraude fiscal y por eso Entonces
esta multa es considerada simbólica hay
que recordar que la organización de
Trump 14 días para pagar esta multa y
que ninguno Ninguno de los integrantes
de la Organización de de Donald Trump
pues irá a la cárcel o tendrá pues
consecuencias criminales personales para
los miembros de esta organización y
respecto al caso de los documentos
clasificados de biden qué preguntas
quedan aún sin responder sobre la forma
en que la administración de gobierno ha
manejado este caso Cristóbal
varias preguntas sobre todo las que se
formulan los republicanos entre ellas
porque si esta información Se conoció
desde noviembre porque el público
estadounidense apenas conoce esta
información esta semana la otra pregunta
es porque estos documentos
confidenciales más de 10 documentos
confidenciales fueron encontrados en el
garaje de la casa de Joe biden en esta
casa tiene el visto bueno de
confidencialidad por parte de el
gobierno estadounidense sin embargo pues
esos documentos fueron encontrados en el
garaje otra pregunta que se hacen
También es qué grado de confidencialidad
tiene estos documentos y que
concretamente dicen estos documentos y
por último una pregunta que se formula
en varios republicanos es por qué
archivos nacionales
la agencia encargada de manejar y de
monitorear esta información confidencial
no tenía idea durante tantos años y
tanto tiempo de que esta información
confidencial estaban en las oficinas de
Donald Trump perdón de Joe biden aquí en
Washington y en la casa Privada de Joe
biden en